[Musique]
alors bonjour à toutes et à tous pour
cette nouvelle émission envies de
lecture la lecture ça important henry
miller disait de temps en temps j'allais
passer une soirée à la bibliothèque
municipale pour lire c'était pour moi
prendre un billet pour le paradis
alors peut-être aller au paradis avec le
livre de sylvain tesson la porte terre
deniz prix renaudot avec natalie voland
maître de conférences à lui vécu puisque
vous fallait au paradis avec lui alors
sylvain tesson bon le quad est tous un
voyageur c'est un écrivain ce jeu c'est
bernard que tu le lis beaucoup que tu
que tu l'appréciés également beaucoup
mais c'était bien et vont se régler très
très très apprécié des des français
aujourd'hui et pense qu'on est nombreux
à voir dévorer un été avec homer qu'on
ait lieu ou pas d'ailleurs déjà l'iliade
et l'odyssée choix que c'était vraiment
un livre qui était accessible
il faut les faire plaisir à tous alors
avec la panthère des neiges des prix
renaudot 2019
on a un rhume à part des fonds via un
livre qui rime bien avec notre saison
l'hiver et sylvain tesson dans ce récit
il nous emmène avec ses trois
coéquipiers et bien sûr les traces de la
panthère des neiges
on part sur les plateaux du tibet bon
c'est pas la première fois qu'on écrit
sur bien sûr ces animaux mythiques sur
ces quelques animaux qui jouent des
rôles particulier il y a par exemple
michel pastoureau qui a écrit beaucoup
sur le parc sur le loup sur l'ours on a
également un livre de peter matthysen
qui déjà dans les années 70 avait écrit
le léopard des neiges
on était parti sur les traces du félin
au népal mais lui ne l'avait pas vue et
sylvain tesson et son équipe et pour
avoir plus de réussite parce qu'ils vont
avoir cette apparition enfin même trois
apparitions et cette apparition elle est
presque sacré t sont écrits et les
religieuses le souvenir de cette vision
revêt en moins un caractère sacré son
pelage marqueterie d'or et de bronze
appartenait au jour à la nuit au ciel et
à la terre le secret des orages et des
nuées d'argent lors des steppes et le
linceul des glaces l'agonie des mouflons
et le sens des chamois elle vivait sous
la toise on du monde
elle était habillée de représentation la
panthère esprits des neiges s'étaient
vêtus avec la terre bon c'est c'est très
poétique celle animal mystérieux c'est
aussi pour lui des visions de la mère de
la femme aimée et c'est surtout ce
journal est bien est une ce journal de
route c'est une expérience qui est bien
sûr charnelle mais qui est aussi
intellectuelle qu'on a comme ça une
écriture
je crois que ça se ressent dans
l'écriture des très belles pages sur le
rapport à l'animal sur le rapport à la
nature c'est une ode à la nature mais
pas que tesson convoque aussi beaucoup
le patrimoine culturel
il convoque gérard de nerval novalis
niche le crépuscule des idoles
le philosophe la philosophie et en
filigrane de ce voyage sur les traces du
félin eh bien il ya une méditation très
intéressant très belle sur nos façons de
vivre notamment dans nos aux aires
urbaines contemporaines alors c'est pas
un rejet de la modernité attention c'est
pas le catastrophisme
les premières séances voilà c'est pas ça
dont un peu à la mode c
c'est beaucoup plus subtil et tessons
c'est un esthète
c'est un esthète qui au fond nous ramène
aux choses essentielles qui nous amène à
nous réinterroger sur le monde et il y a
aussi une interrogation sur le mouvement
n'oublions pas que pour voir la panthère
il faut être patient il faut se tenir à
l'affût des jours et des jours
voilà c'est ça il ya vraiment un art de
la fugue était son nous invite à nous
tenir à l'affût de ce qui se passe de ce
qui va surgir partout même en ville
donc c'est une invitation à regarder nos
façons de vivre à nous questionner sur
le mouvement condamne à nos vies merci
date ali merci mais patrick va nous
parler d'un autre prix goncourt et alors
il ya une ou deux émissions je crois que
dans vie de lecture on a parlé du prix
goncourt 2010 9 de jean paul dubois
ben là je vais vous parler donc du
premier prix goncourt 2009 103 qui était
de john antoine né en californie à san
francisco
et puis qui a pour nom forces ennemies
voilà alors pour essayer de faire vite
aussi ça n'a pas du tout le sera pas du
tout la même atmosphère que le la
panthère des neiges qu'on a vu avant ça
se passe dans un asile d'aliénés
au début du 19e siècle alors on peut
imaginer l'atmosphère de l'asile
d'aliénés avec des déments un petit peu
partout et le héros de l'histoire qui
s'appelle philippe velut saïss il se
réveille un matin dans une chambre dans
un aliment dans un asile d'aliénés
il ne sait pas pourquoi il est là alors
très vite qu'il fait la connaissance de
son de son gardien ou son surveillant
qui s'appelle léonard qui est dyslexique
en fait ils sont tous un petit peu
brandt non mais il faut il faut lire ce
livre parce que il est il et il est
visionnaire il est d'une éloquence
phénoménal et puis il s'adresse à un
cadre particulier avec cet asile où ce
philippe billy ne sais pas pourquoi il
est là il va visiter l'asile avec avec
son gardien alors ils rencontrent des
déments qui sont perchés sur les arbres
parce qu'ils sont grippe à part les a
pas ce qui les fait il est fait l'arbre
pour que la pluie puisse tomber alors il
rencontre aussi un ex docteur qui est
censé dire bien j'ai l'impression qu'ici
tous nos cerveaux ne fonctionne pas
comme il faut etc etc
donc il y là il a épié alors c'est
surtout en visitant avec léonard l'asile
le bâtiment où sont les femmes
il rencontre irène une autre démente et
ils se font un serment amoureux
extraordinaire un saignement amoureux de
dément ils se vouent leur vie jusqu'au
bout et c'est seulement
le philippe soulier en question il est
habité par une force ennemie qui est un
habitant qui vient d'une autre planète
qui s'appelle common
il s'appelle commune et s'est plaint une
planète sanglante où tout le monde
s'entretuent avec le sens il ya que ça
qui compte et c'est donc il a fuit elle
est venue à l'intérieur de l'esprit de
philippe billy alors lui lui il fait
comme il peut avec le avec ce cet
habitant c'est un truc qui est à l'heure
de lui c'est un truc qui lui dit va
retrouver irène et violent là et c'est
alors il s'exécute il va violer l'iran
avec lequel il a faim serment amoureux
de tout ça le pal le mari d'irene la
retenue la retire et lui s'évade de
l'asile philippe ollier pour retrouver
faire une quête de sa femme à travers le
monde et c'est bon je sais pas ce qui
alors à l'époque c'est un certain c'est
un roman qui avait été publié à compte
d'auteur il avait publié au mois de mars
1903 conducteur et puis huysmans qui
était le président du prix goncourt
c'est le premier prix goncourt avec la
première académie avec les premiers
disent qu'ils se qui se réunissait au
restaurant champeau eh ben ils ont ils
ont désigné ce livre là comme le
meilleur livre en prose de l'année
suivant les testaments des goncourt qui
avait voulu que que ce soit comme ça
merci patrick donc pour ma part je
voudrais vous parler du dernier roman de
eric faye
la télégraphie ce de chopin donc eric
faye c'est un grand journaliste il a été
le grand prix du roman de l'académie
française en 2010 avec nagasaki prix
goncourt de la nouvelle également et
dans ce roman il traite de plusieurs
choses d'ailleurs c'est un librement
inspirée en fait de l'avis de rose mary
brawn une angle une anglaise qui est
décédé en 2001 et qui était dans une
famille de médium de ses adeptes de
spiritisme qui qui a assuré qu'elle
était en lien avec chopin mozart
beethoven et qui assurait qu'il leur
dictait des partitions quelques le
réécrivait et que le revendre après donc
il a transposé cette histoire ans à
prague au début des années 90 après la
chute du mur de berlin
alors il ya plusieurs choses
intéressantes c'est la vie après la fin
de tout un système alors il y avait
beaucoup de policiers y avait énormément
de policiers qui se reconvertissent en
détective privé en journaliste alors
c'est l'histoire d'un ancien la police
secrète qui est devenu journaliste tout
ça et on lui demande d'aller faire une
enquête sur une habitante de prague qui
qui assurent qu'elle qu'elle reçoit
chopard qui lui donne des choses à
transcrire et tout ça alors il est
chargé d'enquêté est ce que c'est vrai
ou pas quoi alors je vous dis pas le
laurier tout une enquête et on retrouve
un peu
tout ce dont on croit au médium ou pas
mais c'est intéressant et c'est trés
analyser aussi scientifiquement faut pas
oublier que notre grande poète national
hugo étaient adeptes aussi de spiritisme
pour entrer en relation avec sa fille et
en même temps il ya ce mélange avec ce
nouvel univers à la fin du mur de berlin
mais voilà c'est vraiment intéressant il
ya une belle enquête
c'est très très bien écrit on apprend
plein de choses
alors pour terminer les missions suzy va
nous parler de la scène un roman de
catherine pons taber voilà oui c'est un
livre qui m'a été donnée justement par
les éditions unicité pour savoir un peu
ce que j'en pensais et j'ai été
émerveillé par ce livre parce que déjà
le titre ne dit rien la scène c'est quoi
la scène c'est aussi de notre vie
l'enfant qu'on va avoir et qui nous est
proche tout en étant à la fois un
inconnu et qui sera aussi au long de la
vie un inconnu parce qu'il suivra son
chemin comme il le voudra sans doute
comme il le pourra
et qui n'est parfois pas tout à fait ce
que la mère avait rêvé en début de
naissance
voilà voilà donc je dis que c'est ce
théâtre d'une vie c'est rencontre
improbable entre la mère et son enfant
on sait tout de lui ou de moins on le
croit on fera pour lui mais la vie
parfois en décide autrement la vie qui
est faite de temps d'aller à ces la face
sombre de l'enfant mais le coeur se
souvient de l'enfance et la mer alimente
est happé par l'enfant et des souvenirs
les jeux familiaux
ici tout est bien décrit dans les jeux
familiaux tout simple un universel voilà
tout a fais tout à fait et la mer et à
les croire parce qu'elle est la mère on
a tout simplement elle est la mère elle
est la mère sur la scène de la vie c'est
voilà et puis la mer souvent très
souvent elle vit avec ses souvenirs là
et c'est peut-être ce qu'il a fait forte
grandir en désespoir de tous en souci de
tous en désillusions de tout parfois
voilà et c'était vraiment un très beau
livre qui n'est pas attendue quand vous
l'ouvrez vous vous dites tenté oui bon
d'accord moi je veux bien on lui fait sa
toilette et tout mais c'est dans
l'infime ce c'est ce que j'appelle moi
ce supplément d'âme qui fait la
différence
voilà je peux pas mieux vous dire mais
lisez le lisez le parce que je pense
qu'on va pas vers en tout cas on se dit
oh je parle pas il n'y a pas d'histoire
là dedans qui a toutes les histoires
bonne envies de lecture pour l'année
2020 beaucoup forces ennemies ccc édité
par les par les trompettes marine
allaient tout lâcher sur internet vous
faites les trompettes marine si vous
avez envie de voir le prix goncourt 1903
il va vous le laver dans le 48 heures
dans votre boîte aux lettres
très bonne idée d'avoir très bonne idée
merci patrick merci patrick merci à
toutes et à tous d'avoir écouté
l'émission
bonne année à toutes et à tous et à la
prochaine envies de lecture si vous le
voulez bien
bon bon livre aussi bonne lecture
[Musique]